good morning Hank okay it's a camera
yeah hey why am I doing this uh well
John I'm glad you asked that I called
you so that you could help me help
YouTube announce a brand new program for
the video volunteers program which is
going to prove once and for all how
extremely awesome YouTube can be and I'm
hoping that a lot of people are going to
launch this video watch we're ten
seconds into the video and nothing funny
or gross has happened yet Hank you need
to get a hamster you need to put it on a
piano and you need to feed it some
popcorn
yeah okay I will do that but first could
you tell other people a little bit more
about who we are
oh okay a couple years ago we started
making these videos back and forth to
each other which ended up spawning this
huge community of people called
nerdfighters who fight for awesome and
also raise a lot of money for charity
and sometimes we help them raise money
for charity by doing horrible things
like one time I drank a blender eyes
happy meal in fact Hank that's what
YouTube is about it's about drinking
meat yeah okay that is one of the cool
things about YouTube but additionally
there's the part where it's a real
community of people coming together yeah
coming together to watch old episodes of
Al's yeah to watch old episodes of Alf
but also took their world a better place
do you remember this use project for
awesome thousands of youtubers make
videos supporting their favorite
charities I'm sorry Hank but is there
any way we can get you to talk about
this stuff well a baby named Charlie
bites your finger can you take this
little bit more seriously okay how about
would put a squirrel on water skis and
we tie a banner to its neck with all the
stuff that you want to say about charity
Jon we take a seven-year-old kid to the
dentist we get him all hopped up on pain
medications and then we have him talk
about charity okay actually these are
all good ideas actually I think at least
two of them are illegal I stand by what
I said they are good ideas and now
thanks to YouTube's video volunteers
program click my face for the league
everyone the YouTube community has an
opportunity to partner with one of these
nonprofit organizations and help bring
attention to their causes
you know Inc it occurs to me that there
are people who are really good at
changing the world who like go outside
and interact with other human beings in
that hyper physical medium called real
life and that kind of volunteerism is
totally important right but now there
are also important volunteer
opportunities available to obsessive
Agoura folks who love to edit
like us so if you go to youtube.com
slash video volunteers you'll see a
bunch of different charities that need
creative people to make videos
explaining their work and why it's
important
click my face for the link I'm
partnering with in gender health and I'm
going to partner with the book Wish
Foundation so we're going to make videos
for our charities upload them share them
with people the charity we'll share them
with more people and we hope to see
videos from all those guys too out there
in YouTube land and not to belabor the
point but click on my face through this
active video volunteerism the world will
get better yes YouTube for a better
world click on my face and I think
that's all we have all right Hank I'll
talk to you later bye John so YouTube
here's an opportunity to use your video
making skills to decrease the overall
worldwide levels of suck we hope you'll
take advantage of it as we say a
nerdfighteria don't forget to be awesome
you